[Music]
but i've always believed in the power of
business
and i believe that one of the great ways
to be selfless is to be selfish
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
vaynernation how are you it's gary uh i
miss all of you
as you know i have not been doing a lot
of original interview
uh podcasts during this pandemic i've
been head down
with uh operating vayner x uh during
this time
and more recently have been uh super
head down on my v
friends project my new nft project uh
that is just hitting the scene
but um i had a pre-call with this
gentleman who i'm going to introduce in
a second
and it was just so clear to me that our
ideologies
really really mapped and and he caught
me at a great time we caught
we spoke while i was in california
drawing
my v friends and writing the words
empathetic elephant and
kindness and and and passionate that
and in sympathy and curiosity and many
many
many things around leadership and while
i've been writing
a new book that comes out in november
and as this distinguished gentleman was
speaking i was like wow
we really see the world the same way and
i think we're also in a place where
we both want this way to be the way
so without further ado i'm going to let
him introduce himself and
tell you a little bit about his new book
that i couldn't be more
excited for many of you to read i know
the vayner nation tends to buy
up the books of the few authors i ever
put on here so i i think this one's
gonna hit for you
because i know this audience extremely
well but without further ado
how are you yes gary it seems that we
may be brothers from
maybe from a different brother a mother
but such a good feeling
so my name is uber um up until
a few months ago i was chairman and ceo
of best buy where
together with my wonderful team we led
this delightfully
amazing and surprising resurgence
of best buy and i studied a new life i'm
now a professor
at harvard business school but
importantly this author of this book the
heart of business
leadership principles for the next era
of capitalism
and say that say that one more time
because i want people to really hear the
title of the book
so it's the heart of business
leadership principles for the next era
of capitalism and
i think that we indeed need a new era
right because
what is striking to so many of us right
is the world we live in
uh is not working well right we have of
course a health crisis but also economic
crisis
societal crisis systemic racism
environmental crisis geopolitical
tensions
and what's the definition of madness
gary right doing the same thing and
hoping for a different
outcome and i think that so many things
that we've been doing are not working so
through the years and in particular
through
the experience of leading this
turnaround and resurgence
i have become convinced that there's a
better formula for the world
i think most of us agree with it but
i'll simply articulate is the idea that
at the heart of business
there's the idea of pursuing a noble
purpose
business being a force for good it's
about placing people at the center
and creating an environment where you
can unleash human magic
embracing all stakeholders in some kind
of
declaration of interdependence and
treating profit
as an outcome but not the goal right
when we think about
life's it's not about making money
that's an outcome it's about being a
force for good
and what i felt gary is that while
suddenly following the pandemic
most people now embrace these ideas i
think all of us are travelers
on this journey eager to let go of the
old way and learn how to lead from a
place of
purpose and with humanity and i wanted
to offer
you know help and tools and practical
advice and concrete stories about
what it takes to do this because i feel
i've learned so much so
i hope that will be helpful from that
standpoint
we're you know you're a
a little bit ahead of me in in years
but even for me i always struggled when
i first came into the business world
because it was so about you have to have
sharp elbows don't let anybody walk all
over it was very masculine
and not even masculine that's unfair i
actually want to take a step back
because for a long time i would always
say
i had these skills that my mom gave me
i'm like my mom their feminine skills
when i was in my 20s 30s
now it's just human skills like
compassion empathy
there's unlimited men with that it's not
there's unlimited women with you know
alpha ultra like you know so i think
that that's a misconception but even
even taking it a step back i
always struggled with that because i
didn't
i thought i was a killer i really did i
thought i was a businessman killer
but i didn't think it had to be i
thought business like sports
meaning when i was doing business i
wanted to win
the most competitive i still am i want
to build the biggest
but but when i would meet a competitor
at a restaurant
or meet a competitor at a conference
i had the ability to look at them as a
human being and say
you know do i want to beat her do i want
to beat him of course
but i'm surprised by how many people in
business are nasty
are spending their time trying to tear
down the other person
because i've always looked at business
like sports you could be nasty
on the field but when the game is over
you come up to the person you say how's
your wife
uh can i make a donation to your charity
i saw that you posted that the other day
oh man you really got me today i'm gonna
get you next time
and i don't think people and i think the
term
business is business is a negative term
it's like
but i actually think it's a very true
term but i want to spin it and make it a
little bit like you see where i'm going
and that's why i'm using sports
profound what you're saying and you make
me think of my good friend jim citron
who's one of the senior guys at spencer
stewart who many years ago
wrote something very profound because
the best leaders
don't climb to the top they are carried
up one of the diseases in the world
other than covid
is the idea of zero-sum games only way
for you gary to win is if i lose
tell them vice versa that's right that's
crazy i think we have
to step back and think about
why do we work you know what
you know and work is such an important
part of our life so it's a it's an
important question
is work a curse punishment because some
dudes
in paradise uh or is it something that
you do so that you can do something else
that's more fun like
if you're in minnesota having the
vikings beat the green bay packers
or you know if you follow the lebanese
khalil gibran is work
love made visible is work
love made visible and i think it is it's
part of our fulfillment
as human beings and why do i speak about
this in connection with business because
i see a company
as a human organization made of
individuals
working together in pursuit of a goal
not a money-making machine
a human organization made of individuals
working together in pursuit of a goal
then you ask yourself what is the goal
and that's why you have to look inside
during the lockdown right if you
couldn't go outside
go inside and i think at the heart of
every human being is a desire to do
something good in the world
and the good thing in business if if my
friend
if and i don't know you if
they were fortunate enough to have the
foundation you know
my mother like i'm so happy
grateful content that my ability to do
good for the world
is unlimited because i'm not searching
for anything for myself
that's right i think that a lot of
people are unable to do good for the
world
because they're hurting themselves if
you're hurting
it's impossible for you to do for others
you're so
self-consumed yes however
i believe one of the reasons you know
i've always believed
i mean i'm listen i'm pretty like
socially like
accepting and love and blah blah blah
blah
but i've always believed in the power of
business and
and i believe that one of the great ways
to be selfless is to be selfish
and that's why i've always felt that
business and that's why the fact that
you
you did say in the subtitle the word
capitalism right you said that yep
see that really caught my attention that
was probably the final piece when we
were talking
i remember it now because i was on the
in malibu driving on this highway
it's such a negative word to so many and
i think it doesn't
does not have to be that's right and i
think what you're trying to do and what
i'm trying to do if we rewrite it
because i believe that i am i am making
and i
expect for the next 50 years to make
such a profound legacy
using business and capitalism as the
engine to good not the reverse
that's exactly right and one of the
things by the way you said
gary is about winning and so in business
of course we want to do well but one
thing i've learned
is uh in order to win
you know how do i define winning i now
does i do not define winning as being
number one so at best buy
you know people thought in 2012 when i
became the ceo
that amazon was going to kill us right
yes everybody talks about that
and uh in strategy i actually don't
believe that i need to define my
strategy as beating amazon
it's about being the best company i can
be
and there's room for different types of
players in fact from a strategic
standpoint it's better if i build
something that's completely unique
and the irony in the in this saga with
amazon who is supposed to kill us
is we did neutralize them because you
know at best buy we made sure we had the
same prices
uh same let's start right there let's
start right there yeah
i love that you started with that i in
both my core businesses
both and there's a lot of different
people listening here and that's and i'm
sorry to interrupt i know people get
frustrated with me but
i i have a style and i want people i
love the intensity
thank you when i'm interrupting you
you know it's exactly right right like
but you said something very important
i believe the number one reason
incumbents
lose to new variables in retail
is their ideology around price
you said it so subtly which is why i
jumped in both my businesses
my dad's wine store and my advertising
agency
have thrived on price it is very
difficult
to tell a person why they should pay
more on a commodity
it is incredibly hard right to say hey
hey paul you should pay more at best buy
than on amazon
uh because we because we have many
stores and more overhead
because we because we will talk you
through it here on the floor
i'm sure when you walked in the
frustration i mean i saw it
during that era people would come to
best buy and other retailers
do their homework and by the time they
were out of the store and in the parking
lot had bought it
in a an online retailer for less price
your decision to not let them out price
you
how much was that resistant by cfos and
short-term financial people
how big of a fight or non-fight tell me
a few minutes on that story
i know it's off topic but it's not off
topic for the people that are listening
to this podcast
so i want to spend two minutes on it my
friend yeah and the the journey so
back in 2012 right it was called show
rooming what you just discussed
and i spent my first week at best buy
working in a store in san cloud
minnesota so i could
listen from and learn from the front
liners and see what was going on
and why the showrooming phenomenon was
not
completely widespread it was happening
and stepping back i said look i
you know i want i want to win with the
customers
there's no logical arguments for
preventing the customers from doing this
so i'm going to take price of the table
now we did study we had done a pilot we
had quantified the price gap
so and then the question was you know
what's our choice right we can
continue to carry a price premium and
die slowly
or we can align our prices win with the
customers
in our own way and we'll have to fund
you know the investment in price we
quantified it we funded it through
efficiencies and also we found we we
were able to think outside the box and
again
avoiding zero-sum games and that was the
partnerships
we did with the the world's foremost
tech companies that opened stores within
our stores
you know which helped offset our entire
cost structure
and so you know these principles of
being focused on the customers
neutralizing amazon
but then trying to become the best
version of best buy
by by trying to think through what are
the unique problems
that our customers have and what are the
unique ways that we
at best buy can use to solve them
uh and and win that way and uh
so that was our our focus and that will
explain the the resurgence of best buy
and then that led us to actually
cooperate with amazon because we sell
their products in our stores
and then we even did the deal where they
gave us the exclusive rights to the fire
tv platform to be embedded in
i remember tvs which was huge with
craziness
so it was a different way to think i
want to refuse
a big lesson gary that you and i think
shares refuse zero sum games that's the
difference maybe
with sports in the super bowl there's
only one winner in space
all of us can win if we play a different
game we have to well
there's speed than everybody else there
to your point there's another layer
to this conversation where i'm
fascinated which is
for me the process
is the winning not the
numbers or the money for me i'm winning
every single day
like if if you said actually i'm not
this great
executive and author i'm actually a
genie from the future
and i came on this podcast gary to tell
you your future and i have some bad news
today is
actually the apex height of your
professional career financially
that you will never earn more you will
never earn more
notoriety influence legacy this is it
this is the moment
literally starting tomorrow
unfortunately something's gonna happen
and you're gonna
not collapse but you're gonna flatten
out and
literally my answer to you would be like
but am i still playing like do i still
have businesses
and you'd say yes i would be smiling
cheek to cheek
i think the winning for you know is
the process definitely for entrepreneurs
i have more compassion that it's a
slightly different game for gentlemen
and women like yourself where there's
boards and the market
where there's variables of time limit
you know what's great about being an
entrepreneur is you're playing for life
there is a little bit of you know if i
was the ceo of hp or best buy or
dunkin donuts there would be an inherent
understanding in my mind
i don't control all the variables and at
some point here
others may innuendo to me even if i do a
great job for 12 years hey
the next person's ready she wants to
leave if she doesn't get your job we're
gonna need you to be
executive chairman and i would
understand that but i but i do think
the people both executives and
entrepreneurs that fall in love with the
process
are winning on a daily basis thoughts
yeah and i think the way
i would describe it it's all about how
we define winning and it's all about
purpose and meaning
for me so the fundamental question for
all of us as leaders
is who are we how do we want to be
remembered what legacy do we want to
leave
what's the meaning of our life in fact
one of the
exercise exercises i have so i coach
ceos and
mentor them or at harvard business
school we have this new ceo program
we ask them to write down their
retirement speech or even better
their eulogy so what really gives you
energy
what drives you and i think if we can
connect our work activities
with what drives us which for most
people is doing
good things to other people right
then that's the definition of living a
meaningful life
and when i think about my life i want to
i've always used three criteria right i
want to do something that's meaningful
that's impactful and that's joyful and
to your point it's the journey
right now i do believe that life is
about growth
right that's the definition of life and
so whether but you can define growth in
many different terms
in the late clay christensen writer
wrote this book about how will you
measure
your life and you get to decide this
and i think as leaders this may be some
of the most important question what's
what
you know what is meaningful to us and by
the way one of the things i've learned
gary at best buy is being curious about
what drives people around you
and really understanding their life
story what gives them joy what gives
them
energy i had they had a storytelling
manager in boston
he would ask every one of the associates
of the store in his store
about 100 of them right what is your
dream
at best buy outside of best buy what is
your dream
write it down in the break room my job
as the store gm is to help you
achieve your dream now that's meaning
and to paraphrase godfather
you know tell michael actually liked him
it was only business
nothing personal i think business needs
to be personal
you know and that's a huge shift and to
me that's the heart of business
it's placing people at the center and
finding ways to unleash human magic
you know not even ourselves but in
everybody around us and everybody at the
company this is when you get
organized how do you think about firing
i think a lot of people are listening to
this might get some great value out of
your perspective
how do you think of the process of you
you've obviously
have fired many people through your
career it's the nature of the game
you know how right or am i making
assumptions no
so so let me say a few things but it's
very different
uh from the top of the house to you know
the
the front liners and so forth when i
studied at best buy
it was i'm sorry real quick i i
apologize my
but you didn't start as ceo i did the
best buy i did
i know that i'm sorry i'm trying to take
your whole career into account yeah i'm
talking about you the
human more so than best buy as you went
through your journey you've
obviously had to go through that
difficult process of letting people go
yes
yes so i think for me you the ceo
of best buy and and you know as a fan of
sports
and business that victory is a big one
because to your point
when when i saw that on paper i'm like
this is going to be hard
but i'm actually you're actually on this
podcast because i'm more interested in
you the human being the whole
part because i think so for me take me
how about even maybe the story of the
first person you had
ever you know for me i'll tell you i'll
share something vulnerable
i used to have to ask my father to to
fire people because i disliked it so
much
yeah uh you know so just curious for you
as somebody who's emotionally
intelligently
charged comes from a place of humanity
yeah
it took me only into my last couple
years where i'm like oh no
this is not i'm doing i'm not doing them
a favor by them staying here
no it's better you know but i didn't
really believe it in my 30s i'm starting
to believe it more now
there's a way to do kind candor to get
them there
i'm just curious about your journey with
firing so
several things one at the macro level
when you need to improve the performance
of the company one of the beliefs i've
developed
is that reducing head count is a last
resort
which is the opposite of the usual
playbook company announces restructuring
10 000 positions eliminated share price
goes up i think that's horrendous
the priorities are grow the revenue if
you're going to go
cut cost first focus on non-salary
expenses
which is all of the elements of the cost
of it should have nothing to do with
people
which is usually the bulk of the cost
structure and treat head count reduction
as a last resort
because usually people are not the
problem to paraphrase well dragon
people are the solution you know they're
the engine
that's at the macro level at the micro
level
so just one individual
you're right the uh what you find is
that
sometimes people are not a good fit
you know they they may not have the joy
in the job or it's not a good fit for
their skills they're struggling
everybody knows they're struggling
now if it's the case in the junior
position then you help them grow
but at the top of the house you know
it's too
costly to have the wrong executive i'm a
big believer i'm a bit of a maoist so
don't report me to senator i believe
that fish rot from the head
i agree and oftentimes you have to
quickly remove
people who are not a good fit you know
but you don't
add insult to injury you'd say you know
let's talk this is not a good fit but
you know
as you look for your next opportunity
i'll support you
and so you have to have in your heart
the fact that a it's a responsibility
you have to make sure that
you have the right team at the top
because then it influences
not just one person but hundred thousand
people and that's your responsibility
and then as it leads to the individual
you have a human conversation
around this and that's a big that's a
big uh
thing uh in in you know you have to make
peace
also with the fact that you know
you're the decision maker and
it's not doesn't mean you're right you
don't doesn't mean you need to convince
the person you're right that they're
wrong
is that you're the decision maker and
you've done your best to reach a
conclusion
and then you're gonna do your best to
execute the decision
in in a in a human way there is no point
in adding insult to injury
the common point in all of this is that
the source of everything in business is
people
and they're usually not the problem if
there's a misfit
then you have to deal with it but
without adding insult to injury
i totally understand my friend what um
what stood out for you
in the book writing process you know for
me i'm writing a book
that i think has got some similarities
without reading it yet as i told you i
wouldn't read the book because i'm not
good at that it's not how i comprehend
but i couldn't wait for this interview
when i was
when i'm writing my current book i was
blown away by me realizing wait a minute
i'm dramatically more
curious than i realized
when you were writing this what what
stood out for you of like
maybe a trait or a nuance or a
philosophy
that you even had more conviction or
more belief in or you maybe didn't even
realize
something about yourself or to the level
i always knew i was curious i just don't
think i knew i was
this curious and now a lot of things
make sense it's why i'm innovative
i'm curious and it's not something i
talk a lot about but it will be
you know going forward did anything
stand out to you yes
first it was a very enjoyable process so
here's the scoop
writing a book is actually not difficult
but
writing a good book is extremely
difficult
so you need i needed some help and i
worked with a wonderful partner calen
lambert and it was a very intensive
process we really worked well together
and
the the place the piece that i enjoyed
the most
was writing the third part of the book
which is about
unleashing human magic the first part is
about the meaning of work
the second part is about the purpose for
human organization what it means
the third part is about what it takes to
unleash human magic because i felt we
had learned so much
at best buy but when you have to
articulate something
then you know it forces you to research
and
be more precise and i think this is
and the reason why i'm excited also
about it is my daughter recently told me
that's the part of the book that she
likes best and when a daughter tells her
father especially meaningful
but it was a special moment good for you
and it's the ingredients
about how you know what does it take at
scale in particular
to have everybody at the company to have
a spring in their step
to be super challenged up about wanting
to do great things
in their work and for each other and
what does it take which is the opposite
of what
i think we had learned last century last
century
making getting things done in business
was about you know following
bob mcnamara the former secretary of
defense with the inventor of scientific
top-down management right
you took a bunch of smart people they
created a smart plan an implementation
plan
communicated it put key performance
indicators in place put incentives in
place
that doesn't work and the reason is
people don't like to be told what to do
gary do you like to be told what to do
my friend
no friend i got d's and f's through
school
mainly because i didn't like to be told
what to do
and mainly because i didn't respect a
system
that wasn't willing to react
to the reality of my dna it's it's why i
find so many people losing fighting
in combat sports the people that are
most effective are the ones reacting to
the energy
far off than the ones that are driving
it and that's how i feel about life
you know my my entire career success is
around humility it doesn't look like
that
because i'm very convicted i'm high
energy i'm aggressive
i'm competitive but let there be no
confusion i only think the market
is correct i don't think i always think
they're right
everything that is wrong that i fail is
a hundred percent they were right i was
wrong
the audacity of the market's not ready
for my genius and all this [ __ ] i
hear
is ludicrous the market is the market is
the market
that's exactly right and one of the
other transformations i think
in in business and in leadership right
we
the the leadership model of last century
was the
leader as the superhero was there to
save the days got all of the answers
often driven by power fame glory and
money
nobody wants to follow a leader like
this i think that the
humidity vulnerability my most used
phrase these days is my name is uber
and i need help and i'm curious about
you know what drives people around you
and i know my job
is not to necessarily come up with the
answers but to create this environment
in which everyone can blossom they feel
they can exist it can be the biggest
most beautiful version of themselves
and that's a journey for so many of us
because that's not
how many of us were raised
i totally understand who um who through
your career
either intimately you saw or from the
outside have you admired that you think
captured the essence of this book
uh there's several people who've had a
big influence in shaping it and i'll
mention maybe
three of them one was a client of mine
at mckinsey and company 30 years ago
john married the cow pantry he was the
ceo of a french
computer company who told me he bear
the purpose of a corporation is not to
make money
it's an imperative it's a but it's an
outcome
but it's not the goal you know it's the
profit is the consequence of having a
great team
which leads you to have you know great
customers and innovation
uh and that's what you have to focus on
and one of things he said is
you know when you do your monthly
business review don't start with
financial results
end the meeting with financial results
but start with people in organization
customers business innovation and end
with financial results
and then gary around the same time about
30 years ago two friends of mine
who were monks in a religious
congregation
invited me to work with them on writing
a couple of articles on the theology and
philosophy of
work which invited me to reflect on why
do we work right
this idea that work is part of our
search for meaning which was very
influential the third
person when i was being interviewed to
be the ceo
of calcium companies which is another
minneapolis-based company that's in
travel and hospitality
and zach's maryland council nelson and
she's the daughter of the founder
of the company and it was she was
interviewing me to be eventually her
successor
one of the questions she asked me is
iber
tell me about your soul
tell me about your soul that's the only
time gary anybody asked me that
and you know one of the things we've
realized last year
certainly i've realized more than ever
is that you know the the people around
us are
not just employees they're human beings
they're whole people
and we need to lead with all of our body
parts not just the brain but also the
heart
the soul the guts the ears the eyes
and i used to spend to place a lot of
emphasis
emphasis when i would recruiting be
recruiting or promoting somebody on
experience and expertise i wanted the
best e-commerce person
the best supply chain person
increasingly i spent time on
who is this person what drives this
person
how do they want to be remembered i i
remember telling all of the officers at
best buy when we were talking about
leadership i told them look if you're
here to serve yourself
or your boss or me the ceo of the
company if you think you're serving me
it's okay i don't have a problem with
that except
you cannot work here we are going to
promote you to
customer and we're going to take great
care of you as a best buy customer
because what i want
is leaders who are here to serve others
right and the best way to serve others
is
as you said earlier is to to start from
within right
is to be somebody who's clear about who
they are and who cares about
about others and don't have the sharp
elbows right that's not what we want
so these are some of the people who have
influenced me today in business i think
there's great leaders that i admire
i think at microsoft success is a role
model for me
he exemplifies his vision of leadership
it's about role modeling
caring and coaching i think that's a
great example
my good friend john donahoe the ceo of
nike
if john when he finished business school
he wrote down his retirement speech and
he kept it with him and he's
constantly going back to uh
to that retirement speech to checking
that you know he's leaving
his other idea that he set out yeah
these are examples um these are real
examples
i appreciate that what uh what have we
not touched on before we get out of here
uh that you want people to know about
the book and obviously the book's
available on all
platforms i assume yeah it's available
on all platforms really a book
you know if i had wanted to write a book
for ceos i would have gotten
together you know the ceos of the
business council and
spoken with them for a couple of hours
and would have been done so
this is a book for all leaders at all
levels
and my view is that everyone is a leader
because at the minimum we're leaders of
our lives
and leaders who are eager to create this
future that does not exist yet
but that needs to be a more sustainable
more just future that deals with the
number of ticking time bombs we have
and you know i've written it for you
like taking combines on
whether it's environmental or whether
it's mental health
or whether it's a million other
variables if you actually
used as much of your heart as you did
your brain or your wallet
yeah well then you could have a much
better mix around business yes
exactly and we can be of course good and
this book is an invitation for all of us
to figure to define
what impact we want to have in the world
and how we can lead do a better job
we're all trying i think today
do a better job of leading from a place
of purpose and with humanity and it's a
it's really a playbook a guide practical
set of tools to help leaders fellow
travelers
who are moving in that direction so i
hope it's it's helpful to folks
i appreciate you being on my friend i
wish you nothing but success i can't
wait to buy a bunch of copies for
friends gary i hope this is the
beginning of a beautiful friendship
i promise you it is thank you youtube
watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times uh i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you